hey welcome to the channel design for
leaders and educators
this video is going to be on how to ask
questions to get the answers that you
want this is a question ironically that
i get asked fairly often
my job i get to work with some of the
smartest and most talented
leaders and educators on the planet and
in this video i'm going to share
one major paradigm shift that the
smartest educators and leaders
go through or make in order to ask
really phenomenal questions to get the
answers that they want and the answers
and maybe even more importantly the
impact
that they want to have the only fluff i
like
goes on a sandwich and tastes like
marshmallow let's get into it
[Music]
so half of the paradigm shift is this
when you think about asking questions to
get the answers that you want
on one hand you think about asking
leading questions
right think about a lawyer an fbi
investigator a cop
just give me the facts ma'am right
they're like leading questions they are
asking especially a lawyer right and
court is asking questions
that is aiming to get to a certain aim
and there's this intensity toward it
and the the witness or the person being
asked questions
feels that pull feels like you're
leading them some way
as opposed to over here
really phenomenal leaders and educators
ask questions that
are exploratory rather than leading
and the difference between asking
leading questions over here and
exploratory questions over here
is is quite massive it's the difference
between whether somebody trusts you or
not
it's the difference between somebody
being honest with you or not
it's the difference between increasing
psychological safety and decreasing
psychological safety
which as i shared many of my other
videos on the channel
is the number one predictor of high
performing innovative teams
is the degree of psychological safety
and so over here
these people's job is typically not to
increase psychological safety if
anything it's to make sure your heart
rate's high enough
at least in the movies right if you
happen to be a lawyer or an fbi
investigator
watching this video you get a pass but
the idea here is you want people to feel
psychologically safe
because the answers that i would argue
that you want
i don't know exactly what questions
you're asked i don't know exactly what
landed you on this video
but the answer is i would argue that you
want are the most honest ones
they're the the answers that people um
shared because they meant them not
because they shared them
uh to fit some view of what you
what they thought you wanted right which
happens a lot in leadership
the higher you go in a role of
leadership the more people lie to you
and tell you what you think you want to
hear as opposed to what you really want
to hear
is truth to working with some leaders at
high levels within organizations and
universities and schools
it is a unanimous theme that people have
to work harder
to just get authentic answers authentic
responses from people that aren't
super baked and prepared and
you get the idea in a moment i'm going
to share the paradigm shift in the form
of
some signs that i've got but first
i want to offer you the definition of
adventure and it relates to getting the
answers that you want
because somebody wants to find adventure
for me as embarking on an experience
where the outcome is
uncertain so typically you think
adventure and it's like classically
conditioned with like skydiving
that is thrilling but hopefully the
outcome is certain maybe actually it is
adventurous because
you could die right there's that there's
that element of risk
um and yet a true adventure in a
conversational sense in an
organizational sense
is any experience or conversation where
the outcome
is uncertain i would argue the best
conversations the most memorable ones
the most impactful ones
feel like an adventure you don't know
exactly where they're going to go
they're not
leading questions right
and the paradigm shift that i have
noticed in some of the smartest
people on the planet is moving from a
place of making
assumptions
to a place of exploring possibilities
when you're able to
question your assumptions that becomes
exploring possibilities
but question them in a way that is
rooted in
zero judgment whatsoever
cop fbi investigator lawyer is asking
questions they might be questioning
their assumptions
but they already know they're not even
they're so deeply rooted assumptions
that they
know the answer there's no changing
their mind
on what they think whereas i would argue
that the answers you want to get when
you ask questions are the ones that
explore possibilities
because these are the ones that lead to
new product ideas
better learning outcomes higher
engagement
less turnover in your organization this
paradigm has the potential to
very much shift every conversation that
happens
now if you shift you know one
conversation from a place of making
assumptions to a place of exploring
possibilities
cool but if you do this organizationally
or uh you know across your team
are able to make that shift what you get
is a completely different team
i have a firm belief that our entire
world is created through our speaking
and our listening i can't quite explain
hurricanes with that mentality
or that that theory but the majority of
your world is shaped by speaking
and listening and so when we change
those things i would argue that we
actually change the world so if you're
not happy with the current world that
you're living in
or the current microcosm that you're
living in see what happens when you're
able to shift from making assumptions to
exploring possibilities
now in other videos teach some really
clever tips on how to ask better
questions
questions that begin with how or what
and not why is a really great way to
move from that making assumptions to
exploring possibilities
i'm teaching people how to tap into
their natural genuine curiosity teaching
people how to listen to the music behind
the words because that's usually
where the most possibility lies as
opposed to just listening for the facts
and the words and so training yourself
in more wise ways to listen
really helps easiest lowest hanging
fruits to shift
from this paradigm is very simply moving
from closed questions
to open questions
here there are a lot of closed questions
being asked
yes or no questions things that put you
in a place at a certain time
that put you in a box that don't allow
for a lot of options and how you answer
them right
maybe even multiple choice a leading
question might look like
um hey were you here or were you
here on friday uh january 19th
well you don't have only those options
as opposed to over here
what were you doing on january 19th
right fbi investigator could still ask
that question
but this is a more open question it has
less judgment it pigeonholes people less
and you don't want to pigeonhole people
and if you're watching this video and
you want to pigeonhole people this
channel is not for you probably
because this channel is about create
giving opportunities to amplify
connection belonging and trust and so
move from those closed ended questions
to more
open questions that ask for stories
feelings fears
aspirations the background story
right the the whole picture as opposed
to just one
little image so after watching this
video you're convinced that you
want to have conversations to ask
questions to get answers you
love rather than ones you want you might
really enjoy meanwhile's book ask
powerful questions there's a free
version of it in the link below i'm chad
littlefield
lovely hanging out in cyberspace have an
awesome day